really serious and that i mean are you
feeling he's going to be okay i wish i
could tell you guys i really don't know
um you know i know they're probably
going to do imaging tomorrow just as a
precautionary
um so but i don't know
when joelle is in trouble and gone
and fans want ben to save the day
because they look at him as the other
cornerstone is that fair
for them to see it that way no but but
you guys keep this ben
simmons narrative alive which to me is
freaking insane
how good this guy is and all the things
he does ben is not a 40-point guy it's
not what he does he does
other things for your team and i just
don't understand
why that's not sinking in in our city
i didn't think he was scared at the
moment he just didn't make them so
you know again with ben we're going to
keep him on the floor
unless you guys want to mention the
whole game if anybody
wants us to do that just let me know and
then i'll know you don't know basketball
a little salty there in the post game
because i was listening to that as
it was happening and and doc was tiring
of that line of questioning on
on ben simmons how big a factor how big
a factor can this be
going going forward in the series i mean
i don't know how many games
more it's going to be they have a chance
to win at home and end this thing
but is it a is that a thing right now i
think doc made great points about ben
does so many things however
i think this can be a huge factor
because ben is your playmaker he's your
best play maker
and in the last two minutes if you don't
want to give them the ball because you
think they're going to follow
now you have guys on the court who's not
as good of a playmaker making plays
and he's the best decision maker 100
you know when when they used to file
shaq or they filed away howard
uh totally different because
those two guys have to be given the ball
ben simmons has the ball so
you can file him and he has to make free
throws
in the story because at the end of if
doc says he's going to keep him in
he's going to have to hit free throws to
win a championship because
the the difference is again those two
guys have to be
given the ball one guy has the ball
and so you know when he has it and as
he's making plays
you know shaq is a finisher dwight
howard is a finisher
so now you you're taking
two things away from if you ben play
making ability
and he's not shooting free though and
he's a finisher so all of those three
things are not happening
with shaq it's just like they're fouling
him but they're not really stopping him
from finishing if he wanted to finish
when he has those opportunities so it's
a whole different whole different animal
i've said this before and i'll stick
with it ben simmons is an
all-star he's a terrific player
he can't be a superstar and he'd learn
how to shoot the ball
and shoot free throws he does a lot of
great things
but he can you i don't think any player
can be a superstar
number one if they can't shoot shoot i
mean
attempt shots but also if he's going to
miss those free throws
the sixers cannot and will not win a
championship
uh under these circumstances